the story starts as a single woman named
Anna is having a glass of wine before
going to bed however when she raises her
head she Witnesses someone strangling
her neighbor to death she initially
thinks she is hallucinating but upon
having a closer look it is confirmed
that the neighbor is actually being
killed springing into action Anna grabs
her phone and informs the police then
she decides to rush outside
unfortunately it is raining and as she
makes her way her legs become weaker and
weaker and Anna strangely collapses on
the ground as she closes her eyes the
scene flashes back to the past where
Anna once had a happy family she had a
good husband and a loving daughter one
day the school gives them a task that
requires parents to take children to
their workplace to experience the work
environments so her husband Douglas
takes their daughter Elizabeth with him
to work before they leave the rain pours
so Anna gets an umbrella for Elizabeth
but little did she know that it would be
their last meeting Douglas is a forensic
psychiatrist specializing in serial
killers for the FBI he takes Elizabeth
with him to prison into a room where he
needs to assess a serial killer who is
murdered and eaten 30 people maybe
Elizabeth should have gone to work with
her mom doggy boy just before the
assessment Begins the warden asks
Douglas to step out of the room for an
urgent matter the warden then shuts the
door and accidentally locks the room but
what Douglas forgot is that in the same
room as his daughter is a serial killer
named Massacre Mike unfortunately Mike
uses the opportunity to the fullest and
makes little Elizabeth his 31st victim
the murder of their daughter ruined
Anna's relationship with her husband and
as a result they got divorced several
years passed by but Anna is still shaken
by the incident and to make matters
worse she has developed a fear of rain
as it was raining on that fateful day to
cope with the loss of her daughter and
the breakdown of her marriage Anna has
reverted to drinking wine regularly the
grief is taken a toll on insanity and
sometimes she claims to hear noises
around the house and to see her deceased
daughter Elizabeth this is further
turned her into an outcast in the
neighborhood the only guy who trusts her
is Buell the community's handyman who
specializes in fixing broken mailboxes
there's no way that's a real job Anna
has not dated in a while but one day
when a good-looking man named Neil
Coleman moves into the house across the
street she instantly develops a crush on
him Neil is a widower and he is a
nine-year-old daughter called Emma this
is music to Anna's ears and in order to
get closer to Neil she befriends his
little daughter but to her dismay she
soon learns that Neil has a beautiful
flight attendant girlfriend named Elisa
Anna feels embarrassed after having
flirted with Neil and decides to keep
her distance for the time being however
she continues to spy on Neil and his
family one night while she is drinking
wine she Witnesses Lisa being murdered
and I cannot save Lisa because she
collapses on the road due to her fear of
rain surprisingly a mysterious person
watches it unfold and picks her up later
Anna wakes up on her couch soaking wet
the police who were previously called by
Anna also arrive and investigate Neil's
house however they don't find any dead
bodies and Neil reveals that Lisa is a
flight attendant and is now at work on a
plane to Seattle the police then
question Anna and when they notice a
bottle of wine and some medicine on her
table they suspect she was simply
hallucinating and leave however Anna is
sure that she wasn't imagining things so
the next morning she talks to Neil but
just like the others Neil claims that
Lisa is still alive he even shows some
text messages that he exchanged with
Lisa earlier this morning despite the
evidence Anna is still far from
convinced after Neil and his daughter
Emma leave for the supermarket she
breaks into their home to look for more
evidence near the window she finds
elise's earrings which she keeps with
herself but before she can find
something more concrete Neil and Emma
return home and catch her red-handed she
is then berated by the father-daughter
Duo for crossing their boundaries before
being kicked out of the house distraught
and embarrassed Anna heads to her friend
Sloan and explains the entire ordeal to
her she tries asking for help to
investigate the crime scene but to her
dismay Sloane also believes that she was
hallucinating now because of all the
people giving her the same reason
coupled with the fact that she usually
sees her dead daughter Anna becomes
convinced that maybe she actually was
hallucinating hence she decides to stop
her investigation and visit the support
group she signed up for after her
daughter's death after the meeting Anna
makes a plan to go out of town to clear
her mind but at the airport as she waits
to buy a ticket she learns that there
haven't been any flights to Seattle
during this week this rings a bell and
Anna as Neil had claimed that Lisa left
for Seattle the day before she also
learns that Lisa is currently on long
leave with this information Anna starts
suspecting that Neil has murdered his
girlfriend hence she visits the local
police station and talks to a detective
named Elaine she brings out Lisa's
earrings and asks the cop to investigate
the case but Lane mentions that it's not
enough evidence in fact the only thing
it's evidence of is a B and E Anna
Leaves the police station dejected and
when she gets to her car she finds a
warning stop or you are next despite
this she continues her investigation
when Neil's daughter Elizabeth comes
over to sell some cookies she wins her
trust by giving her a large amount of
money then Anna inquire with the little
girl if she heard anything the previous
night right before the police arrived
Elizabeth doesn't say much but reveals
that her dad and Lisa were constantly
fighting and that is why Neil had set
her to watch television this makes Anna
even more suspicious about Neil the next
morning she looks up Neil on the
internet to her shock she finds out that
Neil was the prime suspect in his late
wife's death however due to the lack of
evidence he was released some claimed
that he tossed his wife into the water
and watched her drown Anna who has a
habit of overthinking starts Imagining
the entire incident Neil took his wife
near the docks and started behaving
rudely with her for no reason then as
their daughter looked on he chucked her
into the water and enjoyed it as she
breathed her last though it's all in Her
Imagination Anna feels her intuition
won't be wrong Anna also learns that a
few days after Neil's wife's murder
Emma's teacher died an unnatural death
it turns out Emma and her classmates
were out on a school trip when the
teacher mysteriously fell off of a
lighthouse strangely in the group
picture Neil is the only parent
president Anna again imagines what might
have happened back then she assumes that
Neil had a relationship with the teacher
in the lighthouse he made several
advances for coitus But the teacher
rejected all of them so in a fit of rage
he pushed her down to her death Anna
becomes more confident that Neil is
behind all of these deaths hence she
intensifies her investigation that night
she spots Neil Dragon a large duffel bag
to his car and becomes sure that he is
disposing of Lisa's body hence she
quickly hops in her car and starts
following him covertly soon they arrive
at a shady looking alley Where Neil
stops his car takes out the duffel bag
and puts it near a dumpster however
before Anna can do anything Neil spots
her and the two get into an argument
Anna accuses him of being a murderer
while Neil is upset that he is
constantly being spied on despite this
Anna is adamant on learning the truth so
she opens the duffel bag she does find a
human but not a real one just a puppet
it's then revealed that to cope with his
wife's death Neil picked up a hobby and
became a ventriloquist oh yeah serial
killer for sure every weekend he visits
local bars to perform and make others
happy just like today hearing all of
this Anna is once again embarrassed and
she profusely apologizes before leaving
seeing how obsessed she has been lately
Anna realizes these hallucinations must
stop so she pours away her entire
collection of alcohol she realizes how
Neil has dealt with his losses by making
ventriloquism his hobby so she too must
find a hobby she starts painting to take
her mind away from her daughter's
Nostalgia as days pass by she starts a
new life until one night somewhere in
the distance a wild dog finds Lisa's
dead body in the woods this finally
confirms that Anna wasn't hallucinating
after all that same night the police
discover the corpse and arrest Anna as
the murder weapon was discovered to be
her painting brush the police suspect
that Anna had killed Neil's girlfriend
due to jealousy which seems to make
sense and has taken aback by this but
she has no way to back up that she is
innocent fortunately the very next day
her best friend Sloan comes to the
rescue and releases her on bail Anna
returns home and later that night she
again start to have hallucinations she
sees blood dripping down from her attic
and immediately suspects that it belongs
to Lisa she panics and calls her
psychiatrist ex-husband Douglas Anna
tells him about the blood and the fact
that she might have actually been
responsible for killing Lisa despite
being divorced for years Douglas calms
his ex-wife down and encourages her to
go up to the attic and face her fears
Anna is hesitant at first but with much
pressure she obliges she slowly heads to
the attic and to her relief she
discovers that the red substance is only
paint however she also discovers that
someone's been living in her attic for a
while it turns out to be Buell the
handyman I knew he didn't have a real
job after a while she again calls
Douglas and explains everything to him
the latter explains that Buell was his
first mental patient he was in jail
because he had brutally taken out his
entire family after numerous tests he
was declared insane but Douglas helped
rehabilitate him and a few months later
he was eventually released Douglas also
motivated him to work and that's how he
became a handyman hearing all this Anna
suspects that the psychopath in Buell
has returned and now he is killing
people one by one lo and behold she
notices Buell walking to Neil's house
with a hammer amidst Heavy Rain scared
that the murderer May kill Neil and Emma
she runs outside despite her phobia of
rain however halfway through her journey
Anna's fear takes over and she collapses
on the ground but as she is about to
give up she finds herself mentally
teleported to the prison cell moments
before her daughter Elizabeth was
murdered by Massacre Mike she also
recalls how no one came to her little
girl's rescue after all the memories
Anna becomes motivated and refuses to
let another little girl get murdered by
a deranged serial killer hence she
slowly drags herself towards Emma's home
and makes it inside however what she
witnesses there shocks her to the core
Anna finds a mortally wounded Buell
lying near the entrance she quickly
rushes up to him and the dying Buell
tells her that he was only trying to
return a parcel that had accidentally
been delivered to Anna soon he passes
away and Anna feels terrible for even
thinking that biwa was the culprit when
he is put in so much effort to change
Anna is a professional at getting
gaslighted just then she hears Neil and
Emma from the living room thinking Neil
is the serial killer Anna rushes to save
the little girl however to her shock she
finds Neil lying dead on the couch with
this Anna finally realizes that it was
neither Neil nor Buell behind elise's
murder the criminal is revealed to be
Emma who appears behind with a bloody
knife in her hand and an evil grin on
her face Emma comments that people
always underestimate children and what
they are capable of a stunned Lisa asks
Emma why she killed Lisa and like a
typical villain the little girl goes on
to admit her crimes a flashback then
reveals that before Lisa was set to
leave for the airport Emma had requested
that she buy some chocolate bars from
her however a fitness Enthusiast Lisa
declines to do so and the lectures the
little girl about health telling her
that chocolate is the worst thing she
could put in her body this infuriated
Emma so she walked up to Lisa with a
knife and told her that chocolate is not
the worst thing one can put in their
body before putting the knife through
Lisa's neck that's actually pretty
clever and is puzzled as Neil was also
present at home during Lisa's murder but
he didn't hear anything Emma explains
that Neil was upstairs in the bathroom
with the water running because he was
practicing his ventriloquist act and
didn't want anyone to hear him she also
reveals that she killed her father
because Neil made her watch his terrible
ventriloquist acts horrified by her
brutality Anna calls her a monster but
Emma quickly retorts that it was her
mother who was the monster the vile
woman got pregnant which was totally
against Emma's wishes as she wanted the
attention all to herself and to finish
off her mother and her baby sibling Emma
spent all summer cutting down the wooden
platform of the dock on the last day of
her vacation she lured her mother
towards the fragile platform as per the
plan the poor woman fell into the water
but the devious Emma just let her drown
like a psychopath now Emma plans to kill
Anna and pin all the murders on her she
intends to play the victim and claim
that she killed Anna in self-defense
Emma says that Anna is the perfect
scapegoat because she can easily be
branded as the mentally ill alcoholic
woman from across the street it's also
revealed that Emma stole and his palette
knife when she went to her home to sell
her Girl Scout cookies Anna is stunned
by the little girl's elaborate planning
and calls her crazy however this only
enrages Emma who reveals that her
teacher also used to call her crazy
until she pushed her off the lighthouse
to her death saying this she attacks
Anna with a knife and even manages to
stab her in the stomach fortunately Anna
manages to fight back and a long
struggle follows the house is wrecked in
the process Anna looks for Neil's gun
but Emma finds it first and shoots her
in the shoulder Furious Anna calls her a
[ __ ]
and lunges at her successfully swatting
the gun off of her hand however the
psychopath girl manages to again
dominate Anna and smashes a plate on her
head seemingly taking her out meanwhile
Douglas leaves for Anna's house fearing
for her well-being as he's not been able
to reach her after she found Buell
living in her attic elsewhere Emma calls
9-1-1 and tells the operator that she
killed her crazy neighbor in
self-defense and the latter killed her
father but just then Anna again starts
moving proving that she is still alive
enraged Emma quickly hangs up the call
and carries the knife to finish off Anna
once and for all she sits on top of her
victim as she is about to deliver the
final blow but Anna picks up a broken
piece of plate and stabs Emma in the
heart finally killing her Douglas
arrives just in time and sees Anna
stabbed the little girl in self-defense
he then rushes to NSAID and asks her to
stay with him assuring her that
everything is going to be fine it's
totally not going to be fine she looks
insane a few weeks after the incident
Anna is declared innocent because of
Douglas's testimony in favor of her and
the plethora of evidence against
fast forward one year and were reunited
with Anna as she boards a plane to New
York and our character happily orders a
glass of vodka sitting next to her in
seat 2A is a mysterious woman who
informs Anna that she's headed to New
York for unspecified business however
after Anna awakes from a brief nap she
discovers the stranger dead in the
airplane bathroom she immediately alerts
the staff about it but to her horror
they mentioned that no passenger was
assigned to seat 2A furthermore they
also reveal that no corpse or any sign
of the crime was found in the bathroom
the story ends as we are left to wonder
is this another one of her
hallucinations or did she just witness
another real murder subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching